he's Bob Saget he's known as a comedian
and he's back on the program here in the
man cave Bob I'll give you the official
introduction here thank you all right
Bob Saget's new special zero-to-sixty
premieres November 14th on Amazon iTunes
Comcast Google Play and many other
platforms the album will be released or
they called albums it's gonna be a CD
and they're doing an LP there I'm
actually doing vinyl and I'll be wearing
vinyl I'm in LA I'm in a zipper outfit
made of vinyl uh known for full house
really Funniest Home Videos oh my god
those are old credits fuller house
I like entourage go ahead keep going but
sorry did you play you and entourage
could not really that's a heightened
version of me I've never really walked
around my house and a black robe smoking
a cigar with a beautiful woman next year
last night actually with my girlfriend
but that's that's allowable did they
approach you and she got lucky last
night I was a little negative last night
I i watch the news I get negative and I
cuz they take stuff in cuz I'm sensitive
so I'm very happy to be here this oh
good
alright cuz you're positive you guys are
all positive we're trying to get
positive so am i I'm trying to put out
today is my start day of rebooting
positivity you can just not watch the
news I just can't handle it right now
but give as much as you can to people
that need help right now
what is off-limits for comedy right now
well there shouldn't be anything but but
it too soon is the old comedy adage and
we're obviously in a world of too soon
because everything's happening so
immediately instant and everything is so
painful so quickly that if you follow
something and you watch anyway the
people that call me down are the late
night hosts you know or the political
satirist but I'm kind of wanting to
detach right now and just entertain
people in many different ways I do a lot
of juggling with my body parts see
that's nonsensical stuff like that you
know just saying silly stuff like that
it's kind of what just like my dad used
to do that's what gets me through did
you grow up with Carson yeah so I grew
up watching I was 11 years old actually
told us because I had been on Johnny
Carson show like 13 times not that I
memorized exactly the number but with
Johnny and and it was pretty the first
time I was home with Garry Shandling
was the host and then
time with Jay Leno and then a lot of
Johnny's and but I was 11 in Washington
DC visiting relative letting a sparkler
on New Year's all by myself and watching
Johnny bring in the new year and it was
he was like a hero I mean he was how
much were you at first time the first
time I wasn't it was really strange
because I felt like I knew him
ranek and I already started I was on a
show on CBS that I got fired from I was
on a morning show yeah before I did full
house and and he just liked me I
couldn't figure out never touch me and
I'll just wait it's called no dead air
is when you say somebody under just just
lays there nobody sometimes in school
guys with headsets and laptops by the
way you know you look at these guys they
seem like nice guys you look at I've met
him before but on your show you've
honored me before by being it but when
you see four guys with head phones and
laptops it can't lead to no good you
know you don't know they're looking at
sports or horses or what Oh
somebody's looking at something wrong on
one of these things okay but if you were
gonna sit on Ted Cruz over there if you
could single out one of the four that'll
trust him fritzy he's got that that
round be face he looks like the little
kid that did nothing wrong what was the
difference between Letterman and Carson
the biggest one
well actually I met David was one of my
first mcs of the Comedy Store in LA and
he just worship Johnny and knew that
Johnny was the best and so he as in
David was obviously incredibly brilliant
and he got a lot of Johnny's qualities a
lot of funny I would go on David show
and I always had the same patter where I
would talk non-stop I still do because
you could tell from from them how many
questions you've asked yes I've gotten
to morning I'm not shutting up and he
gets some people's but the idea is to
entertain that's what I'm here for right
right yeah okay wasn't a question oh
sorry
I was actually interviewing
but I would say to Johnny Carson this is
a true this story's true and he said he
would say I don't care just tell it and
the same thing would happen with David
Letterman I would go this story tree he
says I don't care if it's true just feel
five minutes I don't care and and he was
just but I miss Dave because he was
dangerous yeah and honest as hell but
but these guys now now they're going
after Trump but but they're not
dangerous the way Letterman was because
Letterman could have share on or Madonna
right and Paris Hilton and he would call
him out no he didn't care
yes but this this Elsa there's something
about I miss David terribly and I'm
thrilled that he's doing a Netflix thing
he's gonna do like ten of them I'm told
you know I mean I just I just miss him I
miss Johnny I mean I miss I miss Jack
Paar who don't you miss FDR I miss him
so much
William Howard Taft didn't have died in
a bathtub or something wasn't he like a
300 I know he had a bad set that could
be taken four ways it didn't go over
well no it didn't dent you know right
yeah go not in the bathtub no bathtubs
are bad ways to good showers are bad
when you're gonna want to stay out of
the bathroom there's the worst place you
bombed
I was actually it's in it's in my new
special which won't be on for a month
but I came out early November 14th yeah
right yeah and and it's a it's a cool
thing because it's going on so many
different platforms it's a diff it's a
new model which hasn't happened
I dated a new model once it doesn't work
but this new model is is good and real
and wholesome can you answer the
question no not able Wes long and
courage Alaska in a strip club called
PJs that Jay Leno told us all to go to
because they paid cash and how much did
you get paid to go to I don't remember
well you lose money if you're gonna go
to anchor there's no slot machines it's
just they marijuana was legal and so
were guns so they were way ahead of the
curve and this was I was 24 so this is
like 1982 and I went with Kevin the
and we went on a tour of Mount McKinley
while another comedian stayed in the
trailer with the strippers and and I
followed a stripper and she was
fantastic she was a she lit pie pans on
fire little easy bake oven pie pans over
her nether regions and then blew herself
out this is a joke and then she said she
literally said it now the comedy of Bob
Saget and she said what she loved you
she was hilarious
sweat and sulfur it's all I remember and
for breeze they didn't have it then but
they had some project how much did you
get paid and a good five or 700 bucks I
think for her for like four days or
something oh yeah I wasn't good I think
the flight was I think we we flew in a
FedEx gonna rang a tank he was it was
wonderful times were terrible I mean it
was like eight years of struggling to
try to get a job who's the funniest
comedian offstage wow that's a tough one
most comedians that are really great are
pretty serious offstage because they're
dealing with they're all where
everybody's an outsider so you're going
you're looking at the world you know
your table full of comedians that you
really want to be with the table full of
community no they always show it and you
know they do there's so many television
shows about it and yeah you know dying
up there and all these different shows
and it's not even there's none there
aren't even snarky comments that are
funny and that are you know it used to
be when I was doing it out in the clubs
or whether it be the Comedy Store the
improv
you don't stand around outside and you
know I always found Marc Maron really
funny to listen to just because he was
so dry and honest and but but there's a
lot of people that just aren't aren't
funny they're competing or or sillies
always fun to me or there were someone
coming up with just riffing if you get
to riff with somebody if it's more
improv like then I find that funny but I
can't pick a favorite but there's a lot
of people that I really like that are
that we all like you know that you would
see I just I'm in the middle of post
I've been
editing a movie that I directed that I'm
in and I'm in it with a bunch of friends
and comedians and it's Rob Corddry who's
unbelievably hilarious and Kevin Pollak
and Dave Foley and Cheri Oteri and and
Marilyn Rice cough they're all comedians
and and or or comedy oriented people
like Rob and and that was a great
experience working and they worked
really hard but but collaborative work
together with funny people is a blast
I'm wondering though I brought this up
to these guys that if you could say to
Adele you're not gonna go through the
pain of the break-up that have you yet
that you were able to write this
unbelievable album but 19 I think
then I take away the pain is it the same
way with a comedian yeah you can't take
away the pain the funny won't work like
you would rather go through the pain
well I don't want to go through the pain
you don't but I made that way I mean my
family's pain has befallen our family I
mean we had a lot of deaths since I was
a kid I've lost my parents and they're
here in the car but then you didn't lose
him you know where they are they're not
a lot they're not with us anymore but um
that against the law I don't I don't
think you know long are you keeping them
in there you guys that up google that
he's already famous do they are up and
you know but I lost two sisters I mean
it's been a rough go but you don't know
that's not part of yours actually in my
new special I do talk about the passing
of my mom because she vowed she was
going to return and I asked her please
don't and I and there's humor in you can
you know gallows humor I wrote a book
about it you know death and comedy and
how they intersect and there is solace
in the humor during it with my family
when someone would pass away my dad
would always try to make people feel
better
well we bring up you know paulie's dad's
dad mine is and fritzy so we you know
McLovin and Seton will bring up Father's
Day and hey I got to go see my dad like
right so they rub it in a little bit and
I was gonna go see my dad
yeah chose not to yes and I do that he
lost his dad years ago I lost my dad and
we were there for each other and
and how's your dad always doing great
how's your yeah and it's just a way you
deal with it and you know when things
are really really tragic then you can't
you can't go there but if it's a normal
course of life somewhat it's it's deal
bold
why is it the Irish have it right with
awake liquor is that it well I think it
says I put liquor in with a Jewish
funeral yes that would be and that's the
Shiva that when they get fun no you
don't want like with this corned beef
next I've been to a bunch of shippers
lately what they do is they they don't
at the wake the body is there a lot of
wakes yeah and there's booze because if
there's dead body in the room you want
to drink nor McDonald by the way is one
of the funniest people I would say
because norm has a bit about his and I
directed the movie dirty work with
normies an old friend he just makes me
laugh harder than almost anyone alive
and he was he had a bit about his father
passing away and somebody came over to
him at the wake and said hey would you
like a sandwich he goes I don't know
there's a dead guy dead guy and got a
sandwich with it and that's not even a
punch line it's just it's a situation
but it is but it is it's a custom but
but if you were doing it in a Jewish
thing you'd have the body holding
coleslaw and potato salad lettuce you
know but this is laughing at death and
that's not what we want to do but yeah
cuz there's so much there's so much I'm
I'm hell-bent on entertaining people
right now all right I don't know why
let me add it's the same thing you guys
are doing here your sports takes
people's minds off of stuff and when you
bring politics into it it doesn't really
help but let me take a break here oh you
have to take a break I do I mean you can
keep talking
I will zero to 60 premieres November
14th on a few platforms there it's a Bob
Saget's new special the album will be
released the same day on all digital and
physical audio retailers physical touch
ok and it's on Amazon which means two
clicks you can get the the show and
lotion you know cuz that's how you have
to watch my product I know your honor
right now here we go
that's
20 after the hour I think we'll continue
with Bob Saget right after this thank
you
my Sleep Number I didn't bring my bed
with me to Los Angeles so I didn't get a
great night's sleep just letting
everybody know you tried to put it in
the overhead bin this is a live read is
what this is I like this you know what
what that is it's a Sleep Number bed oh
where where is it now my bed is back in
Connecticut why did you bring it you
need it no remember Don Henley the
Eagles I think was used to travel with
his bed right because I think he had a
bad back but I well I had a woman
strapped to my Sleep Number setting is
60 and a Sleep Number beds cost about
the same as traditional mattresses twice
as long and you know you're in love so
maybe you could use this thing over bed
I got a pretty good bet it's low to
ground so I can't really fall asleep
member Sleep Number no see I got a sleep
member that I didn't get bleep right
there's no you did oh okay you're
ruining my live read 550 Sleep Number
stores nationwide Bob 500 yes in every
state no like all over it's 550 total
it's amazing you can find the one
nearest you by calling one in
[Music]
1-800-225-5935 for house right entourage
Funniest Home Videos those are such old
credits but but no but you did it I did
and I'm proud of it were you oh yeah oh
yeah I would are you proud of it now
proud of it then too it made a lot of
people happy see I would do show I play
a character there's nothing like me
although I do have a Dustbuster you know
and I am a television father that you
can trust which is rare and quiet but
but I honestly love making people happy
and you could watch that show with your
family and then I could go off and do my
stand-up which I I love doing more now
than ever and if it wasn't for those
shows I wouldn't have
the familiarity with the audience where
they trust me to go into my little you
know PG 19 soft hour comedy that just
entertains people that's what I was
what's more surprising when people see
your standup or the fact that you were
in fuller house and well your apple
color house is happening right now on
Netflix and it's doing incredibly well
and but just your father figure and I am
I mean I'm look I mean I'm 61 years old
I ought to be if I'm not if I'm playing
somebody's I'm playing beaver and Leave
It to Beaver up to miss can I see you on
full house and I see you your stand-up
that's it's too different and I'm doing
this movie called Benjamin where I'm
acting in it where you know it's a a
movie where you believe my son's on
crystal meth and so it's a serious kind
of just say no and Samba movie that
indie film and I'm playing a character
that's nothing like either of them and I
just love doing different things and I
love telling a story and entertaining so
I've been out doing stand up against my
even better judgment sometimes because
it's been so rough in the world just to
entertain people and they're so thankful
that fuller house is on had and so I own
it completely and even when we did the
show in the beginning people would say I
lost my mother I lost my father I
watched that show with my single parent
because that's what the show was about
it was a fantasy world with John Stamos
and Dave Coulier were helping me raise
my children and yet the kids don't look
like me they look like Dave so it seems
a little far-fetched though oh it was
based on three men and a baby two
minutes two men in Tom Selleck it was
based on three minutes Stamos was a
little too good-looking for that she's
still too good-looking but I but I'd
like he was distracting well I've seen
him fully fully nude and as opposed to
full nude but you've fully fully fully
fully and upside down he's not but but
he's like a sister to me I mean I I love
both David by the way off stage a coup
ei is one of the funniest people you
guys heard that would like Dave Coulier
offstage I'm not saying he's not funny
on stage because he is but offstage he's
the guy in the locker room that runs her
on naked and doesn't do anything
lascivious but he'll just use his body
as play-doh
this goes look look at me I'm a turtle
you know it's like Dave I don't want to
see that what are you doing but he would
he would just do it to make you laugh he
would use body parts as a thing like a
like kind of like a clown would make
balloon animals
I mean stretch any part of the body any
flies an airplane he's very official and
he's a hockey player guy oh yeah we've
heard of don't have you had him on here
do we have Cooley on you should have
money with his body part but he also
dated Alanis Morissette did he was one
of it that song it was about three
different guys it's a composite is what
she says but I was at his house when he
got a phone call from her and she
actually said I hate to call you during
dinner I was at the house I was Louie I
don't know it's kind of weird she said
she hate to call me during dinner next
thing you know it ends up well but she
she was Taylor Swift before Taylor
Taylor Swift is writing about her
relationships here I think that's what
you get most of your stuff out of I mean
I can't really write about my
relationships because I don't want to be
sued and that's not what it is that
you're a knight I keep stuff and I am in
love you're in love now I am not afraid
to say it
hey and you know you're in love when you
like I don't sleep well when she's not
there and I chloroform myself every
night horror forms not popular anymore
is it it's just not as used as much as
it should
kill a mockingbirds days but uh but
that's a good reference in the morning
yeah they're gonna love that I'm gonna
love that
yeah we're killing there yeah she's good
she's got a whole nobody nobody cares
about
go back to Alanis Morissette okay
[Music]
favorite comedy movie growing up oh
that's so tough growing up too I mean I
loved it too mad mad mad mad world
growing up cuz I'm so old
but then as I got into comedy I found
that you know the older I was when Annie
Hall and and all the Mel Brooks movies
you know Young Frankenstein was way up
there airplane go oh my god
on the roof and is on airplane you know
do you like gladiator movies you've seen
a grown man naked those those and I know
Jerry Zucker and he's a friend and
that's the coolest part is now that I'm
so damn old I to know some of the people
that have made these I met through a
Norman Lear as a friend of mine if I'm
gonna drop some and it's that's a big
what is the limit that you're allowed to
have Polly drop names every seven
seconds I'm disgusting I'm horrible but
but he's genius
he's a genius give me the most famous
person in your phone ma my wife phone in
my phone yeah you're rolling down I'll
just give you my phone I'll be the
company I want you to call everybody
who's in there that I'm glad you in
there I know you do
I'm trying to think I don't know hey
that I don't I can't think about that I
the problem I have is that we all have
is if they have a deceased people in
your phone that's the worst and I don't
remove them I will not my mom's numbers
still in there I know I call it no when
you call Friday that's what gets me like
oh it's not her cuz that sexting it's
all but but I to be honest the coolest
person I met through Norman Lear is Mel
Brooks and that was an idol of mine and
I had been doing I'm gonna play on
Broadway I've been doing this pickle The
Drowsy Chaperone years back and I had
met Mel Brooks once cause Anne Bancroft
god bless her man and I was in love with
her because Robinson you know the
Graduate was a movie tell him the
audience but but she was this is one of
years ago another sounds radio show 25
years ago it's gonna be a 40 minute
story yeah talk about the bed so my
sleeper man Bancroft who's I was
everybody was in love with him and it
grabs me and says Mel you love him this
is Bob he's on that video show he says
get in the car if he goes nodes come us
Bob Saget you love him
get the car well yeah and then she grabs
me by the face shows he loves you we
watch you I'm so sorry that's him I'm
sorry Dan as we say cut to 20 years
later I'm in this play on Broadway and
Mel go sit down and I sit at a
restaurant with him for like three hours
and we had some drinks and Young
Frankenstein had come out on Broadway
and I was in this play and I was doing
pretty good in it he said you want to be
you want to be in it yeah we're gonna
have a new lead for the thing and I said
I can't
a breaking knee you know I got a note
from a doctor and then I just asked him
all these questions and talk to him
about an and he started to cry and and
and he asked about Young Frankenstein
asking about Blazing Saddles asking
about all the things that I thought were
the funniest things that I ever saw and
I saw at a party this is seven minutes
ago I started the Norman Lear story I
asked there's a payoff at a party for
this Norman Lear movie which is
fantastic just another version of you
which is a documentary that Norman it's
about Norman who's the obi-wan Kenobi in
my life it's a genius and and a
wonderful human being
and Mel Brooks cruise over to mean grabs
my head and he yells at me in front of a
roomful of people I'm the only one that
likes you like like kind of like Don
Rickles who was a friend of me that was
one man that's what you were trying to
lose a zoo yes but you won a minute so
you wouldn't let me go to their purse
I'm in it well I'm still grieving over
it well I lost him he was like a dad to
me
you can't do another 20 minute story
no more dad I got to take a break do
whatever you want I'm gonna lay in that
bed what's it called it's a Sleep Number
bed can you lay facedown on yes you can
cuz I like facedown yes is it soft yes
is it softer in the middle he's Bob
Saget his new special is zero to 60 it
premieres November 14th on Amazon and
all different platforms there iTunes
yeah they got it all Google Play you got
it all everything yeah they got it all
the album be release house same day and
digital and physical Oh get rid of the
physical audio retail no we don't want
to because it's a little time left in
that world
I never heard physical I haven't either
physical audio they give you a physical
comes with a gel Bob we it's always
great to see there's a pleasure to be
Bob Saget he was in full house and
America's Funniest Home Videos admit it
I had new things coming has a lot of
news a lot of relevant next 20 years of
career but I want to thank these guys it
is sitting here not speaking and if you
see Bob you know bring up Norman Lear he
loves to tell that everybody named
Norman that's great we'll take a break
here Bob you're gonna have to go okay
Bob is gonna lead
right now I'm gonna standing we're gonna
be back right after this I'm gonna go
buy a break here we go on the Dan
Patrick show the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience